oh
wow
hi hey I'm Daniel I'm Joyce nice to meet
you nice to meet you Joyce I like your
sweater thanks what do you do I'm a
designer designer yeah okay oh designer
why don't you design your exit out this
day why am I always talking like this
Joyce likes to eat cheese and banana
it's a great snack together yes but have
you tried it it's like cheddar cheese
like really sharp cheddar and like a
banana like on this one
foreign
[Laughter]
yeah well you know hold on
wait wait wait wait wait wait he laughed
but his face didn't
[Laughter]
do it again
hi there how are you good my name is
Daniel McKenzie Mackenzie nice to meet
you nice to meet you so why did God damn
Mackenzie ain't she the
the the 35 year old going on 40. yeah
she was the real one all right you look
do I look young no you don't
that's so mean no you
[ __ ] you look older than me why did you
and your last girlfriend break up well
um it was a long distance thing actually
and I was willing to make trips to see
her but she wasn't going to see me
that's who I where'd she live uh
Portland oh that's not even that far I
know really three hours why am I always
talking like this it was frustrating you
know I even got it what happened
because there was a little pause and her
hand went and then she brought up back I
don't think he noticed but the way she
went she like pump faked that [ __ ] but
she pump picked herself because the
light was still blue I'd be like
that are you are you are you trying to
touch the button no no
no no no no no so you're a dancer yeah
I'm a dancer yeah
are you a good kisser am I a good kisser
I think so what about you I think I'm
pretty good yeah I think so I've never
had a complaint you've never had a
complaint in your 40 Years of Living on
this planet no 35 35
. but yeah people don't really complain
they just don't call you back
I've ever had I've never told in the bed
I just never saw them again I don't
think she's a bad guy bro I remember my
kiss one girl one time bro this girl
used so much tongue I remember she left
my place in an hour later I felt like I
could still taste her
you ever you ever you ever uh probably
haven't but maybe you guys understand
this like you ever kiss somebody and
then afterwards your mouth no longer
feels like your own because they put so
much foreign
what's your flavor [ __ ] I really don't
know what's your flavor wow
wow
hold on hold on hold on hold on I'm a
good kisser
Like Fat Joe she did it at the wrong
time
and I can't say you've been rejected
it was so close
why did you reject Mackenzie oh we
weren't into each other we were just
waiting for you to go red
hey how are you my name is Carly nice to
meet you nice to meet you I'm Daniel
so how was your day going are you
feeling nervous are you feeling good
she's giving her that customer service
voice yes so how's your day what can I
do for you can I get you any drinks
before we talk with appetizers of course
ma'am listen we're gonna get right to
the bottom of this just let me put you
on hold while I figure this problem out
this is [ __ ] dumb ah yeah she calls
me original piece she calls me and
starts to talk about excuse me I've been
waiting on the line [ __ ] did I put you
on the line am I the one who made all
the staff here non-existent so that
there'd be long wait times how's that my
fault this [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm going to
leave her on hold for another 30 seconds
pretending like I'm addressing her
problem when really I just want to flick
my bean for a little bit yeah but you
know people won't do that they do that a
hundred I've definitely put people on
hold so I could go down some water
whatever 100 you know I'm a little I'm a
little nervous um there's this little
thing that I've learned that a friend
taught me that if you do get nervous do
a couple push-ups like get your mind are
you gonna do something I don't can I yes
do some push-ups yes
wow
amazing do you feel less nervous I do
actually why did you reject Daniel oh my
that button's foul put the red what
that was foul oh the challenge I would
challenge the big guys I listen
I know I got faster reflexes than you so
I could press this button before you but
I'll let you press this button if you
can do two push-ups and then just see if
she starts sweating
um I didn't think he was very attractive
I didn't like his piano sweatshirt
either very much I love the piano just
not the sweatshirt
hey my name is Carly what's your name
Carlos Carlos and Carly I love that and
I love your tattoos also appreciate it I
love your bubbly Spirit wow you seems so
cheery and happy thank you how old are
you 36. nice I'm 24. is that too young
for you um what's your normal age range
27 to 42 pretty much I mean I'm still
down and kicking like half on a [ __ ]
like that but you know I mean I mean we
could still kick it and hang out
basically means I'd [ __ ] you but I ain't
taking you seriously we are not going
out to dinner but I mean you don't have
suck some dicks out
I got a movie to watch
you know I'll throw some cheese on the
table we can't take it serious though
why I feel like you would grow way more
mature faster than me and then you'd be
like all right I'm out of here but then
when that kind of like bring us back to
level zero then since you're older than
me it's almost better than if we were
this I don't think so
I do like I think that's great though
you're looking at that you're waiting
for that red light that's correct yeah
Carly has never had a boyfriend really
never so what shies you away from not
having a boyfriend is it yourself or you
nobody's pursued you
God damn I was aggressive that was a
super Mike Tyson punch has no one ever
pursued you okay
God damn you want to tell her she's
unattractive it's kind of like it's
never lined up with the right person
oh careful don't touch me
that was scary
sets here nice to meet you my name is
that too I hear you're really good at
armpit Parts my best friend just learned
how to armpit fart she was mad I haven't
learned it yet I'd love to see yours all
right let me do this real quick
yes yes no no she went yes like he was
gonna spit on her [ __ ]
that's what it looked like I 100 see it
I think she's into him I see it that
face is
he went he went and she went
she having flashbacks
oh my God but that was impressive I'm
not gonna lie that was way more
realistic
he went to reach but he was so far back
she saw him she said oh you will reject
me no [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna reject you
yeah
you know the promise with the show the
problem with this show is that
people like out of fear of being
rejected try to reject the other person
faster and so it's kind of like this
weird dance but
people are not really incentivized to
really actually maybe that's not a
problem with the show maybe this is just
a reflection of the fact that everyone
thinks everyone's disposable and there's
always something better across the
corner and so it's just a reflection of
that so think about it yeah they'll do
this whole air I was about through these
hoops but they don't actually want to be
with each other and they know it deep
down inside and so when there's an
opportunity for the next person they'll
lose any sort of Civility to be an
[ __ ] because
that's the name of the game yes and you
then the prize is not getting rejected
so if I see even if I'm if I see that
you're about to do it even though I
wasn't about to do it yeah oh no [ __ ] I
wasn't I am not going to be rejected
yeah I respect your decision yeah of
course the armpit fart didn't do it for
you I press the button on as a defense
move not really an offense move
it's us
that's us
that's uh she reached when he reached
do you want to play right no that's fine
I'm trying to go on a second date with
someone that I like and he wasn't going
to pick me so I didn't pick him either
God damn Fair that's fair but I felt
that
who is this
she hurting on the inside I like your
jacket oh thank you what was your name
sorry I'm Josh Josh nice to meet you my
name is Carly Harley awesome have you
always lived in Seattle or Washington I
was born in Virginia I grew up out here
yeah I just moved from Kentucky about a
year ago we're in Kentucky
um I went or I lived in Lexington I went
to school at the University okay I drove
through there a few times yeah Virginia
is really close there
damn
[Laughter]
you know why I think it is because all
the guys who got I beat you stupid [ __ ]
gotcha there goes your self-esteem now
take that [ __ ] out the door oh wait uh
you can't fit yeah [ __ ] goodbye like
the way they're doing it and why they're
doing it that way I'll tell you why why
because three other guys already went
backstage and they said yo this [ __ ]
might be big but she got that light hair
yeah yeah she got them Hobbit hands so
he said it all works
why did you reject her she was all right
I think she might have been too young to
be honest hot how are you doing good
that's good I'm Josh Debbie Debbie nice
to meet you nice to meet you how tall
are you I'm 6'3 oh wow I like them
exactly
foreign
title song
let's go ahead she's a Manny and I guess
yeah
how does the song go with the word
that's how it goes yeah that's that's
that's how it goes yeah that's I have no
idea that's how it goes she's a man yeah
that's how it goes okay that's a hundred
percent how it goes yeah so I think you
might like me ask him how he would
seduce you oh how would you seduce me I
don't have to take my time to continue
to get to know you I got a deep voice
I've been told my voice is like somewhat
nice talk dirty to her sorry
pretend that you're talking to me on the
phone
pretend that you're talking sexy to me
the phone okay babe I got you
oh sorry Debbie you've been rejected
that was dirty Josh just hell that
wasn't dirty you're giving me an out
there that was far from Dirty that was
uh on the spot why did you reject her I
think a little too too too old
potentially hi how's it going I'm good
how are you good I'm Josh Alex nice to
meet you nice to meet you too what's
your tattoo of uh it's Forgive Me Nots
he's feeling her she's about to hit that
button
um she can't take him back to her
parents no
a little different but the kind of Asian
dad gotta be very open-minded in my
experience Asian ladies ain't open
enough to bring a black dude home most
of the time
enough to get a tattoo like she wants to
disappoint her parents enough to get a
tattoo there's levels there's levels
there's a lot of guy on top of tattoos
look there's levels I might secretly
have an artistic hobby I'm not gonna
drop out of med school so I could sing
on the streets
give each other your best pickup line oh
no how much you go
[ __ ] you first I don't have a pickup
line go ahead I think this is the
classic did it hurt
is this cornball get this cornball out
of here bro did it hurt when you fell
down having hit other penises on the
wave down you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
these are red pill pickup lines
how do you feel about
how do you feel
how do you feel about theme parks
because you look like you've been on the
[ __ ] Carousel and I want my turn okay I
got one I got one I got one I got one
knock knock who's there
what's you what you mean
what you bring to the table [ __ ]
okay knock knock who's there who who
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
let me stop let me stop
[Laughter]
it's not stupid when you fell from
heaven
I'm so painful right
now it's my only one okay so what do you
look for in a person someone who
definitely knows who they are okay right
their purpose what about yourself I
think being able to
use like politics maybe or like
future wise like are you gonna have kids
maybe not are you teetering if you're
gonna have kids or not do you find each
other attractive I think you're
attractive I think you're attractive too
but you sleep with each other
I think that I think that for me get to
know you and see what happens yeah okay
me too this has been a long day how are
you feeling I'm feeling good good do you
think you would consider going on a
second date with each other yeah yeah
for sure definitely do you want to go
out yeah
okay
all right one last time I'm gonna go red
let's see what happens
for the content
hey
let's go you know what happened right
you know what happened right you know
what happened right
she was standing there looking at it oh
he cute yeah I could get with him and
then I was like I'll give you guys one
last chance to reconsider and actually
stand there she just heard her voice off
of the distance say you have brought to
Dishonored
you have Dishonored a family
[ __ ] that's good
that was good why are we so happy she
was
me it's like no I I get it because it's
just like any moment it's like whenever
you're sick and tired of seeing movies
that end well you want to see that one
movie that don't end well Hey listen I
like being wrong I like yeah but I was
right I did something inside of me told
me she wasn't gonna go for it
I'm so sorry
wow I did one last opportunity I thought
you were gonna depressed I know why did
you press I feel like he knows what he
wants and I don't know what I want I'm
only 27 I'm still trying to figure that
out you broke his heart yeah I know I
know
I'm Alvin what's your name Alex Alex
yeah nice to meet you you in school no
I'm not do you if the other one was not
passing this one is definitely not
passing for a reason the other one knows
what he wants and this one doesn't know
anything
yeah you in school word lie yeah that's
dope that's dope I I I I I guess how old
I am 24 27 27 yeah how about you I'm 23.
okay what are you um
[Music]
so smooth with it yeah he's at 27
there's no way you're going to want to
come to my mom's basement uh we're not
[ __ ] on an air mattress there's no
way that you are ever going to be able
to be someone I can afford how old did
you say you were 20 hot 22 Old oh
standards no thank you what was that you
don't want to take the bus oh sorry
[ __ ] huh
you don't like coupons
wow that was a short date why did you do
that it's just uh too old what's too old
for you
25. yeah what a lame ass Fufu [ __ ] yo
listen yo you young kids if you guys if
you guys feel that way y'all lame as
hell bro why listen when I was around
the age of 20 I was going for whatever
listen to 32-35 you just come on bro get
out there [ __ ] was like talk
about uh 23 and she's 27 I said but bro
Scrappy seats if you want it you can get
it now if you're looking for something
serious okay maybe maybe I'll Grant you
and then don't listen to me but if he's
just a young dude y'all here if you're
trying to turn up
[Music]
nice to see you again I sing but I also
love to dance oh can you sing for me
where I can just go any your favorite
one each morning I get up I die little
can barely stand
take a look keep you guys strolling no
he's not disgusting just some people who
are like so socially [ __ ] they don't
know
Jesus
sorry sorry
you know we just said that like someone
said okay
all right sir put your hands behind your
back ah bro I just came out
I think this might be our last button
video in a while if you guys really like
these kinds of videos leave like
comments let us know with the numbers
because I mean I can only handle so much
of these button people they're wild bro
anything you want to say
what's up [ __ ] nice shoes wanna [ __ ]